die schulden vor corona das waren rund
1,9 billionen euro und dann tickte
plötzlich die uhr die vorher rückwärts
lief dann wieder rauf und es kamen 501
milliarden euro neue schulden ungefähr
dazu so dass der neue schuldenstand bei
2,4 billionen ist wir haben das einmal
runtergerechnet auf den bundesbürger auf
den einwohner
das waren vorher ungefähr 22.000 euro
was auch schon viel ist schulden pro
kopf und sind jetzt das machen
anschaulich 28 1850 also nochmal prokop
6000 euro dazugekommen und die frage ist
jetzt sehr stolz machen sie den deckel
für uns alle abbezahlt haben
also das kann ich ihnen gut beantworten
wie wir damit umgehen werden zunächst
mal die usa sind jetzt dabei über 100
prozent staatsverschuldung zu bekommen
wir werden am ende dieser krise knapp
über 70 prozent haben und wieder runter
rutschen auf unter 60 prozent was die
stabilitätskriterien sind wenn wir die
richtigen zukunftsinvestitionen auf den
weg bringen werden wir ende dieses
jahrzehnts anfang der 30er jahre wieder
unter 60 prozent seien alle
stabilitätskriterien erfüllen mit
normalem gutem wachstum das ist das was
uns gelingen kann oder dass das möglich
ist darum geben wir dieses ganze geld
jetzt aus und das ist ja auch schon von
vielen gesagt worden aber auch ein
konsens über den ich ihnen gerne
berichten kann dass wir die
möglichkeiten des impfens aktiv für eine
öffnung strategie des testens aktiv für
eine öffnung strategie mit verwenden
worden das heißt wenn getestet in dem
moment wo flächendeckend getestet werden
kann zum beispiel vor geschäften zum
beispiel vor restaurants kann da
geöffnet werden es wird nicht alles auf
einmal gehen ich glaube das ist ein
guter grundsatz den wir alle miteinander
in unserem leben gelernt haben und das
gilt dann auch für so eine schwierige
herausforderung wie die bekämpfung der
korona pandemie
aber es muss einen schritt für schritt
folge geben die jeder nachvollziehen
kann
und da muss man das testen dort
einsetzen wo es besonders wirksames wir
brauchen auch mehr tests zum beispiel in
den unternehmen ich möchte dass die
unternehmen ihre mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter testen wo wir zu viele
ich möchte dass wir in schulen und kitas
diese möglichkeiten ändern sie bei
einsätzen es muss einen bestimmten
zugang geben dazu dass man tests auch
als bürger einfach irgendwo und am
testzentrum bekommen kann
da haben wir ja auch vor dass wir diesen
weg jedenfalls für das testzentrum auch
gebührenfrei gestalten und das muss dann
eine folge haben für das was an öffnungs
schritten möglich das heißt das testen
das ist absolut im fokus und das ist
jetzt auch kurzfristig ein weg ein
langsamer weg heraus aus dem loch daun
es ist ein teil des weges raus aus dem
block down ganz klar die tests sind eine
zusätzliche neue möglichkeit weil wir
sie jetzt im großen umfang verfügbar
haben können wir müssen natürlich genau
zählen haben wir auch genug für all das
was wir jemals beschließen das muss mit
den unternehmen zusammen rückgekoppelt
werden damit wir auch da keine falschen
versprechungen machen und falsche
hoffnung erwecken aber ja wenn man
testet hat man mehr spielräume und die
muss man genau beschreiben was uns nicht
passieren darf ist dass wir jetzt
irgendwas öffnen und dann kurze zeit
später wieder zu machen wenn ganz
deutschland weil wir uns vertan haben
und die ansteckungsraten dramatisch nach
oben ihnen aber wenn wir sie irgendwie
stabilisieren können und mit hilfe von
tests mit hilfe eines fortschreitenden
impfens in die lage kommen dass wir eine
bessere situation haben dann haben wir
mehr möglichkeiten müssen auf die
inzidenz werte schauen und haben sie ja
und gesetz festgelegt in der der
deutsche punkte in dem gesetz das der
deutsche bundestag auch noch mal
speziell angepasst hat für jetzige
pandemie und deshalb ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir das nicht aus dem auge
verlieren aber wir haben mit viel mehr
tests auf eine etwas größere bandbreite
und die wollen wir auch nutzen weil wir
natürlich nicht aus duffy oder aus
irgendwie verbohrtheit jetzt diese
beschränkung veranlasst haben sondern
zum schutz der gesundheit der bürger und
bürger und des lebens viele größere
bandbreite beim incidents wert durch die
tests
das ist das was wir alle für möglich
halte ja wenn ich das richtig verstehe
aus den vielen gesprächen die ich
geführt habe und jetzt muss man das
richtige maß finden